hi there today was a big day for my
Korean I spoke for an hour and a half
one hour with Joo Hyun with whom I spoke
about a year ago and I'll put a link if
I can find it to that video so you can
compare my Korean at that time too now
essentially all that I've done for my
Korean since the last time I spoke with
Joo Hyun is the three weeks that I've
now put in during my challenge and it's
certainly been the most intensive period
of Korean study that I've ever you know
engaged in I did also another probably
another 2 3 hours of reading and
listening today as I said yesterday I
bought some material from Sun Sun Hill
news talk to me in Korea which is pretty
easy stuff and it's good to vary the
easy with the difficult so I went
through a his audio book which was good
and he'll Jun's audiobook and then he
had a stack of evidence in grammar in a
way it's grammar but he explains the
structure of the language and with a lot
of examples and a minimum thankfully of
grammatical terms and of course my
approach to reading about grammar is
just to let it wash over me as I do with
with content it's just exposure I don't
expect to remember it I've read many of
these explanations examples in other
places and I just kind of read them and
read them and read them and eventually
things start to stick I don't try to
memorize or remember or completely grasp
any of it so I did some of that I
probably won't have time today to get
back at some of my Chosun Ilbo articles
the biggest enemy of the language
learner is time we kind of run out of
time I want to put up here the 15 minute
recording of my discussion in Korean
with kyu Hyun and I don't it's just
simply too much work to put the
subtitles in I'm not going to spend two
hours putting subtitles in my videos but
I have sort of written up a little
script of roughly what we had to say and
I'm going to put this in the description
to this video so that you can read it
and have a sense of what we're talking
about
- here she is a oh hey and yeah hey oh
hey oh are you a Jew or a origami oh hey
one my name reckon I owe a chin hambone
woody I'm Kei gay Alton good on Jay oh
geez on J so check out you if you don't
a ninja chick am done
yawn yawn hey I'm on the way John John
they are mother
Teague jr. he got pinned and I saw saga
day got a hey hey yo hey yo mo ba K a
job an eye on pinned on doh-doh combo
hog weasel tell your uncle donut a
chicken pot with mmm de tumbu major
jungle the moyamoya finishing I cooked a
business okay then it could take it is a
wave oka Joe Tobin rocks and rocks angry
a non-person tree Sumita table aha a
wave of juego game then go on to
understand DD money from Myka hey Molly
next a a crooner to open run this ROM
Israel hey bunny they wiggle sagem some
% o % % Shh easy pass and o day okay
then say gay yoga g-money coke I saw
awesome
hey Lebanon New Mexico Eko mmm I'm
Prakash Autobahn
Oh Jimmy so yoga in Qigong a cushy cushy
bill tojon or not Rajan I saw a cushy
pillow John linka saw leeway one day he
saw a tuck
Kaku yogi like everybody uh Kaku
silently
hey go check on go go
Ichigo a tip - mogi guaçu Santa Corona
parents are underneath Tara no no come
back bees they they take a nail video
among Google a upload ago isn't hey Joe
Kenda homicide Nate Ichigo are Givenchy
pin and or dead Taj on highways only cop
hey how Google fighting there
Shivam yoga your magic on go yoga G in
go haha - Kohaku Sumida a chill chain in
busan Chosun Ilbo thank you so chose an
Evo
hey so mundari linkit toy Pago [ __ ]
Tomoko he'll go Savita the - boom Hank
okay so Tong Tong Tong gee yogi Mon jaga
is assumed is Asuna
you know Iran a cognate
oh good way dang Tim one day hey come G
come jack
they killed a young gay we all ready to
go hon Google the backup soo hyung look
Juanito
yo gotti hey come up with a good Santa
I do Jimmy sir hey hey hey hey Joshy God
Amador pin Nando shin bone a shin bone
Simon Simon Oh mmm
yo soy su Meachem similar children full
of oil
aha Toya Toya come to the table for go
ahead mmm cuckoo ping on the shamone
shamone one Johnny
Lincoln toy penguin the cop ah
international I am aa cosmic ax okay the
Chilam mmm no not all Martin on all
Matalin a Finland a a Khumbu a on jihadi
rounded young Yankee
the Eco young a hungry crew terrazzo
panic alt a hungry troll torrents swiss
only come on Thomas a ah a male baby
have a gate or a zombie come on yeah Oh
Christmas earthquake on something oh the
yo jump on rock to none oh don't give a
yarmulke mm oh yeah under coil and a
copper and Oh
I claim it so much
Toma how do you say hey serious hmm
yo engine are you in general I know
serious yeah grand tonight the he-yump I
saw Paran narrator Cheick Kongo Khan
Taurus a turn
nerado cargo ships Amica cargo ship will
take on Sweden Sweden motya now Hey
negatory caballo
and luckily I go I do Jimmy soil to
gamble like TV are we gonna be so yeah
Digga Rigga us Rocha st. Petersburg
I do I do Jimmy saw the pure law
actually especially Toki know especially
tookie-tookie a cool what a cool
no no sorry yo you want you want a good
name you are when I'm not there
M you have Finland butoh mole Tiana day
you are a Finland huarache a heart shape
what it's sunny until late ah no no k kg
hey yeah hey yeah yeah yeah hey I'm Jo
hey gonzo I just saw st. Petersburg
granades yeah won't you not know a see
everywhere everywhere Oh Higgins OD
Dungey Jamie sue check our money Nara
Nara Park moon soo ji so Europa's Oh
Nami to Khurana a I am sir
your daddy Naro tominaga krola a oh no
dough kombu ham okay
crappy Nando Amado each one each one
ship yo she knew the hmm
Simeon Kali who shiny chrome goo ha ha
myung you Johnny ping Nando also have
you say will be hustle hustle coil
actually take a house is super Shh
hey Kang woo boy Sango guess or pin and
pin and owe you Johnny
also in on surround a money up so oh
they're thinner pin landing
Zubaz oh you Changi hanbok how students
are hungry chuck amato
money up so today yeah Melanie John I am
young
yeah you try on Google how Sinan pinned
on do in Arizona Cup hey uncle and key
London Singletary oh we can google Congo
I'll go in the car kisara k-pop k-pop
k-pop tangle a day keep up Bravo Chicka
Tonio Muro Muro Muro
ah TJ k - K no red hey update no harm
jicama drama yoga yeah
Jimmy Crona Qigong drama take no more
loose or yo-yo motto a handle to doubt
hue suga hyung Google drama mmm
Pogo a here hal su isseulkka yo chicken
a magic book on chosen that day chicken
mmm
Tommy is Tommy shigani optimist sugar
and Totoro hey sign up hey hey Tom 800
how do you say record no look it's not
look um okay no hey no hey Choi in ha
mmm how do you say Timbo Timbo a em
tongue proof or record kill thank you
yogurt Linda okay okay
our unique a co- AR